[Music]
i had a roller coaster life switching
jobs businesses and pandemic was of no
excuse for me but after finishing my
course last year and making myself a new
career in data analytics getting myself
a new job i really felt calm and which
i'm grateful for last two years was very
tough for me just like many of us but
i've decided to utilize the time in a
productive way and what can be more
productive than self-improvement and
learning hi this is aswar and i live in
chennai i'm an aeronautical engineer by
education but a data analyst by
profession i did a post graduate program
in data analytics from simply learn with
purdue university after finishing my
course within two months i got placed as
a data analyst with oxford international
while i took this course in order to
improve my business and trading skills
my journey took a turn completely after
completing this course after graduating
in 2017 i moved to a non-technical role
with jediways as an aviation security
officer then i started my clothing
business in 2019 but again i was hit in
a roadblock after my clothing business
went to a downhill during the pandemic i
started a new business on construction
materials where i got the chance to work
with multiple clients all over india and
that is where i've realized that data is
very much essential for business
after comparing the course with other
platforms
i felt that the course offered by simply
learn has got the best content
after reading all the reviews and videos
from other learners which gave me the
confidence to actually apply for it as i
was new to data analysis the trainers
were helping me to understand various
topics
along with the self-paced recorded
videos were of great help in clearing
all my doubts i always had a keen
interest in share market and crypto
trading to understand this better i
wanted to study python and to better my
analysis my knowledge of python and
predictive analysis has gone from
strength to strength throughout this
course now i can say i'm doing my
trading with better analysis and with a
minimum loss this certification not
alone improved my resume it also gave me
a cutting edge from other candidates i
think it doesn't matter where you come
from what your education background is
or what your fears are as long as you're
headed in your right direction
i always believe there should never be
an ending to learning